la question est encore plus radical que
ça puisque la question qu'on peut même
se poser c'est ce qu'on a bien fait de
confier sans le confinement nous aurions
eu beaucoup plus de morts mais mais
effectivement il ya il ya des abus
[Musique]
vous êtes nombreux dans vos commentaires
a dénoncé le confinement une mascarade
on en a marre trop de gens ont été mis
au chemin alors at-on trop confiné le
débat est intense chez nos intervenants
à commencer par brice couturier
chroniqueur à france culture
à l'opposé guillaume bigot et ceis
politologue et ancien conseiller de
charles pasqua et enfin claire chartier
journaliste et chef du service idées à
l'express ils ont des avis qui vont
parfois étonnés ils sont toujours
argumenter
je vous propose de les écouter ce choix
du confinement
on n'a pas en avoir honte dans le sang
sont finalement il correspond tout à
fait aux valeurs qui sont les nôtres
nous sommes en europe berceau historique
des lumières nous avons fait le choix du
conte contre les utilitaristes anglo
saxons en quelque sorte nous avons
privilégié le principe du respect de la
vie de la vie des personnes sur les
conséquences des mesures prises ces
conséquences ce sont la paralysie la
paralysie de l'économie
et puis évidemment les difficultés de
vie des gens on peut répondre de manière
catégorique non ça n'a pas épargner des
vies parce que dans d'autres pays il ya
moins de morts et d'autres pas ah oui ça
lui en effet cataclysmique au plan
économique ou à payer le lourd en passe
toujours très très mal quel que soit le
gouvernement en place ça aurait été
pareil avec un autre entre la population
et son rendement en place donc
effectivement on a dû recourir à ce type
de mesures
hyper autoritaire que je moi je trouve
ça fait déplorable a franchement en tant
que libéral d'autres commentaires en
revanche eux dénoncent le déconfinement
et voudraient certains restés confinés
jusqu'au 31 août
on n'a pas assez confiné il y a beaucoup
de morts et une courbe qui ne diminuent
pas ils dénoncent la décision d'avoir
des confiné à partir du 11 mai alors ces
commentaires sont ils compréhensible
oui je comprends tout à fait précisément
parce que qu'est-ce qui a présidé au
confinement
c'est que nous ne pouvions pas être
assurée de d'avoir les latitudes
notamment sanitaires pour répondre à la
pandémie
donc là est ce que nous avons ces
garanties la non non je les comprends
mal je les comprends mal parce que on va
pas devenir non plus une espèce d'une
ans ce critique où l'état qui n'a plus
d'argent parce qu'il est endetté à 100%
continuerait à payer les gens du public
et du privé pour rester chez eux
si on a dit aux gens si vous sortez
acheter votre peau vous risquez de vous
retrouver en réanimation
personne n'a envie d'envoyer d'abord ce
que nous avons de plus précieux les uns
les autres c'est à dire pour ceux qui
ont des enfants nos enfants et il en va
de même bien sûr des personnels de
l'éducation nationale sur la sur le plan
de scolaires je comprends un peu moins
dans le sens où après tout des tas de
soignants aujourd'hui s'expose aux colis
de 19
bon là qu'envoyer des enfants à l'école
alors qu'ils sont moins deux
transmetteurs je trouve que ça c'est
peut-être un peu plus sujet à débat
alors si certains comme les soignants
comme les employés de supermarché comme
les livreurs ont pu continuer à
travailler
n'aurait-on pas pu faire autrement
sur le moment sans doute par mais
maintenant avec le recul on voit qu'il
aurait pu faire au trou puisque d'autres
gouvernements ont fait autrement n'ont
pas pratiqué au piment strictes ont
pratiqué un camping à dison sélectif
visant à protéger d'abord les personnes
à risque je pense que c'était absolument
impossible et on le sait tous et parce
que nous encore une fois parce que le
les hôpitaux le n'était pas capable
d'encaisser en fait massif de malades et
que on le savait précisément à partir de
cet élément
des tas de personnes et notamment âgées
personnes allaient mourir
donc je pense que ça ça n'était pas
concevable pour un pays comme le nôtre
avec la culture que nous avons il est
évident que les pays d'asie du sud est
fait beaucoup mieux que nous et ça
devrait nous amener à réfléchir
effectivement question subsidiaire ne
pouvait-on pas faire comme en corée du
sud comme à taïwan comme même en
allemagne en partie tester travailler et
éventuellement avec ceux dont on dispose
et traités dont hydroxy chloroquine la
fameuse thérapie qui défraie la
chronique
son efficacité ils sont
l'été n'est pas complètement démontré
par les fameux tests en de miser en
double aveugle et comme le gouvernement
est derrière le prendre sa brique
complètement derrière le principe de
précaution et comme par ailleurs le
gouvernement a très peur de la
juridicisation de la société et des
juges
il s'est dit prêt si ce traitement n'est
pas totalement totalement fiable et
n'est pas sans risque aucun traitement
évidemment des sans risque on ne peut
pas se permettre de le diffuser et il a
pris des mesures assez drastiques et
donc on voit conférer pavé de bonnes
intentions
j'aurais été sur les masses comme sur la
question d'hydroxyde chloroquine la
volonté de surprotéger la boucle la
population fait l'exposent il faut faire
comme les allemands effectivement il
faut faire confiance dans la population
il faut arrêter d'embêter les gens en
leur interdisant d'aller sur les plages
de l'atlantique dans l'est ou dans les
forêts des yvelines qui sont absolument
vide et nous on risque absolument pas à
me rencontrer qui que ce soit affecté à
part peut-être un sanglier ou une ou un
poisson échoué sur le bord de la mer sur
la bord du sable mais il faut faire
confiance un peu plus aux gens il faut
que les gens fassent un peu plus
confiance à le gouvernement même s'il a
fait beaucoup d'erreurs et qu'on peut
comprendre l'agacement de pas mal de
jambes
on aurait pu ce qu'on aurait pu faire
c'est fermer les frontières très vite
bon agir plus mais mais franchement
l'une avions très peu nous avions très
peu de levier donc je pense que
sincèrement c'est pour ça c'est pour
cette raison que la mesure drastique du
confinement a été prise
l'exigence démocratique impose
aujourd'hui d'aller regarder pourquoi
n'avez-vous pas si vous avez apprécié ce
débat si vous avez apprécié cette
controverse
merci nous le dira pas un pouce levé sur
youtube et bien sûr de partager cette
vidéo n'oubliez pas de partager vos
commentaires et de nous donner votre
avis
[Musique]